y llegó la hora de hablar de economía
aquí en directo América por ello me
acompañan el estudio mi compañero Juan
Pablo lucu mi hijo Juan Pablo bienvenido
hoy tuvo lugar una importantísima
reunión un momento que se considera
histórico la primera reunión entre dos
grandes superpotencias hablamos de los
presidentes de China y Estados Unidos
así es Valentina Buenas noches pues fue
como dice usted la primera reunión en
persona entre Joe biden de Estados
Unidos y chilling Pink de China una
reunión Pues importantísima porque
recordemos que son la primera y la
segunda Economía del mundo
respectivamente y aquello Pues que ellas
decidan básicamente afecta a los
mercados de todo el mundo por ejemplo
recientemente el dato de inflación de
Estados Unidos marcó la hoja de ruta de
los mercados mundiales y revirtió las
pérdidas de los principales indicadores
bursátiles y por el otro lado la
decisión del gobierno de China de
relajar las medidas anti covid y
recortar la cuarentena dio lugar a que
las relaciones comerciales con varios
países mejoraran conside y dio
esperanzas a los comercios sumidos en
constantes cierres sin embargo es una
relación complicada que depende de las
movidas estratégicas para darle un
ejemplo a inicios de agosto byden firmó
una ley para impulsar la fabricación de
chips de forma local y así competir con
China escuchemos
como saben me comprometo a mantener las
líneas de comunicación abiertas entre
ustedes y yo personalmente pero nuestro
gobierno en general porque nuestros dos
países tienen mucho que tratar como
líderes de nuestras dos naciones
compartimos la responsabilidad En mi
opinión de demostrar que China y Estados
Unidos pueden gestionar sus diferencias
evitar que la competencia se convierta
en algo cercano al conflicto y encontrar
formas de trabajar juntos en cuestiones
globales urgentes que requieren nuestra
cooperación
mutuas
bueno como era de esperarse se escuchan
palabras conciliadoras para rebajar la
atención Pero pero pues Juan Pablo fue
una reunión de casi tres horas qué
conclusiones salieron de esta Cumbre
pues las tres horas demuestran la lo
complicado que fueron algunos de los
temas que trataron ellos pero pues no se
conocieron avances determinantes O al
menos decisivos de esta reunión ambos
dijeron que buscaban evitar una nueva
guerra fría y para ello pues esperan
establecerse como un par geopolítico Sin
embargo vaiden reprendido a China por
las prácticas comerciales coercitivas la
estricta política cero covid de China y
las provocaciones militares contra él
autogobierno de Taiwán pero como una
movida estratégica dijo que Washington
seguía apoyando la política de una sola
china bueno Amazon Parece ser otra de
las grandes tecnológicas que se unirá a
los despidos masivos Así es Valentina
pues esto según un adelanto del medio de
New York Times quien informó que
posiblemente esta semana por lo menos
10.000 trabajadores de Amazon perderán
su puesto aún Pues el hecho no es
oficial él este despido no pero hace dos
semanas Pues dijo que había decidido
pausar la contratación corporativa
porque la economía estaba en un lugar
incierto esto luego de varios resultados
negativos de las proyecciones de
ganancias que tenían para la empresa
algo que pues le ha pasado a otras
grandes tecnológicas de las que hemos
mencionado aquí los polémicos despidos
despidos de Twitter que fueron
recientemente los de meta de Facebook e
Instagram y la aplicación Robin Hood por
solo mencionar algunos De cuántos
despidos estamos hablando Cuántas
personas de toda su planta Pues se trata
de aproximadamente el 3% de los
empleados corporativos propios de Amazon
y cerca del 1% de los 1,5 millones de su
plantilla laboral de alrededor del mundo
recordemos también que Amazon es una de
las principales empresas empleadoras de
Estados Unidos Entonces pues no es para
menos que pues estos 10.000 posibles
despidos que se den bueno seguimos con
empresas tecnológicas porque Google
aceptó pagar por sus prácticas de
movimiento de ubicación como es esto así
es Pues se trata del mayor pago en la
historia de Estados Unidos por parte de
una entidad privada ante una demanda
presentada por varios estados El gigante
de tecnologías Google aceptó pagar cerca
de 392 millones de dólares que exigían
los fiscales de por lo menos 40 estados
de pues Estados Unidos recuerde que la
ubicación pues se puede activar con
Google y puede rastrearnos pues a muchos
de nosotros para que la empresa pues
mantuviera sus prácticas de ubicación
según reporte dice que Google recopiló
información sobre la ubicación de
consumidores que intencionalmente habían
pedido que no lo hicieran con esto
Google ahora deberá Mostrar información
adicional a los usuarios siempre que
activen o desactiven configuración de la
cuenta relacionada con la ubicación Juan
Pablo vamos con Los indicadores
económicos de la jornada Así es pues las
bolsas en Estados Unidos cerraron a la
baja este lunes luego de que los
inversores evaluaran los comentarios de
los funcionarios de la reserva Federal
para tratar de determinar el camino del
Banco Central para de las tasas en
contraste los tres principales
indicadores europeos tuvieron ganancias
al cierre y en nuestra región tuvimos
otro panorama un escenario mixto luego
de que la bolsa de México perdiera un
0,34% frente a las ganancias de
0,181% de la bolsa de Sao Paulo de
Brasil y las ganancias de
1,52% del principal índice de Buenos
Aires Juan Pablo Muchas gracias por esta
ampliación económica que es aquí con
nosotros en directo América que ya vamos
con directo